[Música]
10 com tutu arcebispo da cidade do cabo
disse assim não é nada mais político do
que dizer que a religião não tem nada a
ver com política
então eu queria falar sobre essa
complexa relação entre política e
religião religião e política
e falo isso a partir do meu blocos
evangélico
eu sou pastor evangélico e os
evangélicos somos uma voz nesse brasil
polifônico nós falamos e começamos a
falar e falar alto e essa voz está sendo
ouvida e essa voz dos evangélicos
graças a deus também é múltipla a voz da
igreja evangélica no brasil é o iphone
cá e eu falo de outro lugar de dentro da
igreja evangélica
esta tradição que a herdeira da reforma
protestante
esse movimento do século 16
no contexto de hegemonia do catolicismo
romano e é bom a gente comemorar os 500
anos de reforma e olhar para a história
nesses 500 anos de protestantismo porque
é quem não conhece a história está
condenado a repeti la é do hamburg
filósofo britânico
me parece que nós estamos repetindo a
história por ignorância do que foi esse
movimento ali no século 16 que passou a
ser chamada de reforma protestante
era um tempo de uma voz só era um tempo
de uma voz que pertencia à igreja a
igreja romana que emprestava o seu poder
ao império o clero e o rei o clero ea
coroa se uniram e criaram uma estrutura
de poder e deixaram o povo ali no chão
tendo a sua fé ea sua experiência de fé
instrumentalizada o papa inocêncio
terceiro chegou a dizer que assim como a
lua empresta do sol o seu brilho também
o rei recebe da igreja o seu esplendor
a voz do papa ea voz do imperador era
praticamente a mesma voz era uma
compreensão de mundo determinada por uma
orientação de percepção da verdade uma
orientação hierárquica é isso construiu
aquele contexto mas você sabe que quando
a política instrumentalize a religião ou
a religião tenta instrumentalizar a
política ambas se perdem foi o que
aconteceu na idade média e você deve
conhecer a velha história e esse
fenômeno das indulgências quando a
igreja começou a cobrar para conceder o
perdão dos pecados
era comum naquela época dizer que uma
moeda que caía no cofre da igreja era
equivalente a uma alma que saía do
purgatório comércio com religião é uma
coisa muito antiga
quem não conhece a história está
condenado a repeti la até que chega um
momento em que alguém mais precisamente
martinho lutero se levanta 1517 outubro
exatamente o próximo mês vamos comemorar
a i os 500 anos da reforma é fruto de um
processo histórico martinho lutero se
torna símbolo e esse evento símbolo da
reforma protestante é o dia quando
lutero a fixa nas portas
da catedral de vita velho na germânia as
suas 95 teses convidando a comunidade
acadêmica e os religiosos os teólogos a
debater a questão das indulgências
lutero deflagrar um movimento religioso
inicialmente ele não imaginava talvez a
repercussão do que ele estava fazendo
até que em 1521 é chamado a se retratar
porque ele questiona a igreja
ele questiona a autoridade do clero do
papa da sacrossanta a igreja e ouso
afirmar que existe verdade fora dos
limites da igreja
ele ousa oferecer no seu contexto
histórico uma outra voz que confronta a
voz que estava unida ou unindo o clero
ea coroa
lutero é chamada se retratar na dieta de
formas e ele diz assim eu não vou me
retratar porque nenhum homem deve se
retratar caso isso necessite ou exija
que ele negue a sua própria consciência
surge daí na reforma protestante o
princípio da liberdade de consciência
a liberdade de consciência que resulta
também na afirmação de que todo ser
humano é responsável por si mesmo diante
de deus e que não a intermediação alguma
de ninguém de nenhuma instituição e de
nada entre a pessoa humana e deus a
consciência humana é responsável e capaz
e competente pra ouvir a voz de deus não
existe mais a igreja aqui no meio e
quando lutero fala isso quando os
reformadores falam isso falam da
liberdade de consciência falam da da
competência da responsabilidade da
pessoa do indivíduo diante de deus e
quando eles dizem que a igreja não é a
mediadora dessa experiência religiosa ou
dessa experiência de fé nessa
experiência de salvação
lutero faz surgir mais do que uma nova
consciência religiosa ele ele ele coloca
uma semente que vai fazer brotar uma
nova consciência política porque quando
a igreja é detentora exclusiva da voz
divina a hierarquia social se percebe
como deus a igreja eo povo mas quando os
reformadores eu estou usando o nome de
lutero simbolicamente porque foram
vários mas quando os reformadores
disseram não
cada pessoa na livre consciência é
responsável por responder a deus a
hierarquia é mudada
agora é deus o povo ea igreja ea coroa
essa máxima que todo poder emana do povo
e em nome do povo deve ser exercido tem
muito para em texto com essa índole
protestante não é mais a igreja quem
tutela a minha consciência
a igreja não impõe para mim a minha
confissão de fé a igreja não dita mais o
meu padrão moral de comportamento
eu agora sou responsável com a minha
liberdade de consciência eu sou
responsável por responder a deus como eu
consigo discerne lo como eu consigo
perceber lo como eu consigo nele crê ou
não crê
isso faz com que haja não apenas uma
revolução religiosa uma revolução
política mas uma revolução do pensamento
rei vai dizer que com lutero
nós chegamos à era da liberdade do
espírito e que a revolução ensejada pela
reforma protestante foi a revolução
fundamental até que chegamos nos nossos
dias
essa compreensão de uma sociedade
polifônica essa compreensão de uma
sociedade plural
essa afirmação de uma sociedade
democrática
essa postura de dizer ninguém dita regra
pra mim sem ouvir um eu protesto
ninguém me diz como eu devo viver o que
eu devo crer sem que o questione e as
idéias que me são apresentadas as
propostas que me são feitas ou eu me
aproprio delas na minha livre
consciência ea partir desse momento em
que eu me aproprio essas idéias e essas
propostas se tornam minhas
então a partir desse momento eu sou
guiado pela minha própria consciência
ainda que as idéias tenham vindo de
outras consciências mas eu sou guiado
pela minha consciência porque eu sou
responsável
isso gera uma nova postura de
civilização
isso gera uma nova realidade social
por isso veja que interessante quem não
conhece a história está condenado a
repeti la
eu penso que os reformadores deve estar
se revirando no túmulo no brasil
religioso de hoje três exemplos
essa exposição de arte daquele banco em
porto alegre que por motivos religiosos
ea força religiosa fez pressão para que
as portas fossem fechadas dizendo isso
não é a arte
essa
esse protesto contra essas são de arte
eu não consigo entender não interessa
que fere o senso estético o meu senso
ético meu senso religioso
eu sou protestante
todo mundo tem liberdade para expressar
o que crê o que pensa e viver do jeito
que quer
eu até admitiria que alguém fosse
protestar pelo fato de que o banco vai
fazer uso de lei rouanet é uma vergonha
mas protestar uma expressão de arte
a minha consciência
isso não faz sentido há 500 anos que
houve uma guinada na cultura ocidental e
que trouxe a afirmação da liberdade de
consciência da responsabilidade do
indivíduo por exemplo a peça de teatro
foi censurada na cidade do rio de
janeiro na cidade de jundiahy agora
recentemente o evangelho segundo jesus a
rainha do céu em que jesus seria
representado por uma mulher transgénero
as forças religiosas foram lá e disseram
não pode censura para com isso
de onde veio isso isso é medieval
isso é uma imposição de crença e de
moral não é nada protestante medieval
quando na cidade do rio de janeiro
a pichação bíblia assim constituição não
silval
nós estamos numa sociedade polifônica
porque há uma sociedade guiada por
consciências livres e por consciências
livres e responsáveis e essa sociedade
ela será tão saudável tão livre quanto
mais possibilidade de que todas as vozes
se manifesta em todas as vozes sejam
ouvidas todas as expressões de crenças
de fé
todas as expressões moraes todas todas
as propostas de construção social
por isso cada vez que alguém vem impor
um padrão de crença de ideologia de
proposta política de moral de código de
comportamento as consciências livre
sempre dirão eu protesto
eu estou num movimento que protesta há
500 anos
eu espero que a releitura ou no mínimo o
conhecimento da reforma protestante
contribua para um brasil polifônico
porque ainda
é questionável em termos de substância o
solo para a experiência religiosa para a
construção de uma sociedade justa e
igualitária
vale sim a máxima vox populi vox dei a
voz do povo é a voz de deus
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]